[Music]
theme three is will we ever uncover
deep metaphysical truth about reality
and perhaps we can turn this more into
deep metaphysical truth about experience
and patricia i know earlier you said i
don't really that's not my question my
question is you know how how can i help
with that pain what does it mean to
affect perhaps the brain so that the the
pain goes away but i'd like to put some
more pressure on you um in relation to
whether that also means that there is
something there there is something on
the level of the being of that of that
thing that you are
examining or or or whether you you don't
you don't think so
well obviously some uh theories are
better than other theories and
um hypotheses get falsified all the time
and that's true not just of neuroscience
but if it's true of science in general
and um
what precisely makes one theory better
than the other now here hillary would
say that i have to talk very very
puritanically and i mustn't say certain
things like we're getting
by virtue of the theory being more
predictive and explanatory powerful i
mustn't say that we're getting closer to
reality so i won't say that
but we do know that there are
differences uh in in theories and i mean
for example
with regard to pan psychism and the
claim that protons and cow pies and
fungus are conscious
it seems to me to be kind of outlandish
i mean i don't care if people want to to
hold that but there seems to be no
evidence for it there's nothing about a
fungus that we know that
shows that it's conscious under some
conditions and not under others and
ditto for protons and ditto for cow pies
so some theories are better than other
theories and even those may crash and
burn as yet more data
uh
come to the fore but i think hillary's
being a bit prissy in insisting that we
be precisely careful to never say
that we're getting closer to an adequate
model
okay all right give it a rest let us you
know i say the sun sets even though i
know full well
that the sun's not moving
uh and
as a very you know demanding semanticist
you might say i cannot say that
otherwise i look like a dingbat
well okay fine
uh but but let's say
that that there is something about
certain models that makes them more
adequate than others and if hillary
feels we'll never know what that is fine
or be it for me to complain
okay
so
it's
very very interesting
because i i i think that
in some ways we might have a a similar
uh response to pan psychism so i share
your feeling that it seems a bit
outlandish to uh
claim that um all elements of nature
have consciousness and it you know i
take a sort of occam's razor type
response you know this seems like a a
bit of a bit of a big move to make so
in in the practice of this
i think that we we might well share a
lot in terms of which models we want to
go with and but the reason why and i
also accept your criticism that in some
sense i'm being unduly rigorous in
saying oh we we really must be careful
not to
uh talk about uh ultimate truth the
reason i guess i'm encouraged to do that
is because i think that it does have
profound consequences referring to uh
ultimate truth uh i think it affects the
way that we all interact with each other
we operate in a world where in which an
awful large awfully large number of
people in the world think they're right
they think that there is a way of
thinking about things and they're right
and other people are wrong and i think
operating in a framework in which you
give up
this
notion of a
a an ultimate reality actually gets you
into an exciting space where you have
the potential to develop your models or
i would say closures of the world you
have the potential to make them more
powerful but you are not in the
situation of thinking that there is one
right answer and you are open to
alternative ways of thinking and but but
i share with patricia that there are
some that i think well actually that's a
bit of a big move for me i i i would but
galen might be able to convince us and
that's why patricia mentioned it because
galen's a supporter of the pan psychos
theory as i understand he might
he might says he's not but but he might
be able to convince vince me actually it
really will work
and you really can't and it's more
powerful and in which case uh i will i
would say okay
i'll go but that's the basis on which i
would be operating okay well very
briefly i mean first thing is that
occam's razor cuts the other way pan
psychism is is the most parsimonious
theory not the not an excessive or
exaggerated one
because the only thing we absolutely
know for certain is the existence of
qualitative consciousness so anyone who
says
so we know that's one thing we
absolutely know about reality i'm afraid
i have to say about ultimate reality so
the qu anyone who thinks that it's not
all like that is positing um some other
stuff which is non-conscious stuff with
no evidence for its existence there's
zero evidence for it i'm not saying that
pancreaticism is testable it isn't it's
not a scientific theory it's just it's
what it is it's technically it's an
inference to the best explanation that
is
what do we know for sure
what do we know for sure about reality
we know that there's consciousness now
uh do you really want to go on about
this i mean so um
either it's all that it's there all the
way down or it's not so let's suppose
it's not that suppose the stuff at the
bottom is in no way non-conscious then
you have to suppose that somehow
consciousness emerges from this stuff
that is in itself wholly and utterly
non-conscious you have to commit
yourself to something called radical
emergence and that is a huge burden that
is a real no-no for any theory you uh
whereas so that's the sense in which
span psychism is a simple more
parsimonious more elegant simpler theory
and i don't you know i can't claim to
believe that i don't know that it's true
but i just think it's clearly the most
hard-nosed theory out there
you mentioned the difference between
science and um and philosophy or
different theories and i'm wondering
whether one way to bring out what you
three agree on or disagree on is is
whether you think that
philosophy is needed at all or we could
do everything with science when it comes
to understanding what experiences or
what pain is um galen would you like to
go first i don't think what do we need
to understand i know what pain is
i know what visual color experience is
you mean from a first person um yeah but
that's that's the only way you ever have
direct access to it anyway i don't think
there's any problem of understanding the
problem only arises when you think of
the physical stuff as being completely
different and wonder how you get the
consciousness from the stuff that's
completely different
so that's precisely what a panzakis
doesn't do does that mean then that you
would be okay with philosophy kind of
taking a backseat and and sometimes
there are some distinctive look there
are two here's a free will is very so
we're going to talk about that later
that is a very clear example of a purely
a priori topic which is um can be dealt
science has nothing to say to it and and
philosophy gives a very clear answer to
it so that's one such topic
uh patricia what what what are your
thoughts about the the
whether there is a need for philosophy
or whether you would be happy for
science to replace philosophy
well it kind of depends on on the
philosopher i mean there are
philosophers who are doing really
interesting work um
and then and and uh
so so these philosophers look like
scientists
no i mean and you mischaracterized my
my position by saying that i thought
only logic and analysis
would give you adequate concepts um in
the in the future
that's just not not something that i
thought of
but
but the fact is of course that
speculation is very useful in science in
all sciences
and people speculate in order to put
together a hypothesis that they might go
on to test
and although galen thinks he knows
everything there is to know about
consciousness because he has it he
doesn't always have it he doesn't have
it when he's in deep sleep aren't you
curious about what you what's going on
when you're in deep sleep yeah have you
ever had a blood yeah have you ever had
an anesthetic
have you ever even had a tooth pulled
where you had a local anesthetic aren't
you interested in what happens
yeah no it's okay not to be curious
about the natural world i understand
that
and there are many things there are many
things that you like to do other than
think about
causality and think about what
what causes certain kinds of changes in
consciousness
but uh i happen to be interested in
those things
and uh that doesn't mean that that you
know there's some that that i have some
sort of
failure of personhood because
not every metaphysical crackpot that
comes down the pike is interesting to me
hillary i feel you want to say something
in response yeah yeah so so on this
question about science you know i i'm
all in favor of the
principles of of observation empirical
observation and reason as i said at the
outset and i'd want us to
employ those and look at our models but
i don't think that science has
uh somehow
stumbled upon
the only way of discovering uh better
ways of intervening in the world or
indeed that um it's ever as i was saying
going to arrive at a correct one so in
the conversation that's
going on here i think the idea that oh
we're getting either to the bottom of
consciousness or that
we can uh
have experiments which will
define the answers i think we've got
many many different ways of talking
about consciousness if we look at the
way that different cultures across
history have talked about consciousness
they would have had countless different
sorts of story and the sorts of story
that we operate are very valuable in
some areas so
our greater understanding of brain
processes and how that might lead to
consciousness may help us deal with
certain conditions and so forth but
there are lots of other ways of holding
the world which are uh powerful in in
their own right and will enable us to do
things that the framework of
contemporary science perhaps doesn't
enable us to do and uh
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas